- On the way in here I passed Bonnie
who's on the ground (beep) passed out
because of this pie.
I don't wanna try this.
This is (beep) up.
(static)
(suspenseful music)
- So today I'm trying the flaming ron
which is apparently the hottest meat pie.
- I'm really nervous I'm gonna die.
- I've seen a few people
run out of the room.
So I don't like this.
- I really don't think
it's gonna be that hot.
- I have to sign a
health and safety waiver.
- I've never signed a
waiver for food before.
- I'm aware that this product contain
the hottest known
ingredients on planet Earth
which could lead stress to the heart,
asthma attacks, and other problems.
- So the only times you
ever really have to sign
a waiver is when you're about to die
and people don't want to get sued.
- Alright.
Bring it on.
(suspenseful music)
- Holy (beep).
(upbeat piano music)
(gagging)
- Oh my god.
- I usually don't tear up
but I feel like I'm about to cry.
- Oh man.
I can feel that going all the way down.
- I just need some milk.
- Oh (beep) dude that's (beep).
- They said to eat a cucumber.
- Damn that's hot.
- That is the hottest
thing I've ever eaten.
(choking)
(sniffling)
- I definitely understand
the disclaimer now.
- I feel like my brain might start
dripping out of my ears right now.
- This does nothing.
- I just vomited outside.
But I think that's because I skulled
a liter and a half of warm skim milk.
- I'm gonna need a tissue.
Holy crap.
- For the people who can eat a full one
how the (beep) are you alive?
- That's the most intense thing
I've ever had in my mouth.
- I feel like I'm gonna die
and if I don't die I want to die.
Lord.
- To the makers of this pie
hats off to you.
You have made something
that has ruined an entire office.
- The flaming ron has bested me.
- I would give you a funny line to end on
but there's nothing (beep) funny
about this (beep) pie.
- I would like to go.
I'm taking this.
Oh my god.
(upbeat piano music)